so first of all thank you so much for
the warm welcome
I'm an enormous fan of this city the
first time I was here 17 years ago I was
here on a wine trip and before I took a
very late like 2:00 a.m. flight we got
back to the city from wine country
around 7 and I went to the casino and I
played poker and I don't know how to
play poker but I was put at this table
with a bunch of 70 and 60 year old
Russian dudes and since I was born in
the Soviet Union and speak Russian
something very interesting happened they
saw me as an American boy and they
started talking an enormous amount of
[ __ ] so the night was going on and on
and on I was getting completely
destroyed because when I tell you I
don't know how to play I really don't
know how to play but finally got to like
1 a.m. and they're kind of cleaning
house on me and I've gotta like leave
pretty soon and I get some ridiculously
decent hand I go pot committed I catch
something on the final card and I take
all these old [ __ ] money and I looked
at them dead in the face and basically
said go [ __ ] yourself in Russian and the
look on their faces to died of a heart
attack and literally that's why I love
this city
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
what up it's a great outfit what up what
up what up can't read that sign but
that's a [ __ ] good effort all right
let's sit let's go so the way I asked to
form a forum Matt this talk is mainly to
do QA which has worked in Brisbane and
Sydney so I'm gonna kind of pontificate
on a couple things that are currently on
my mind and I would highly recommend
many of you if you've got a question to
probably start lining up even now the
mics are right there and right there
let's talk about a couple things
before we get into QA one I get very
fascinated about the concept of this
conference in itself I always spend a
lot of time thinking consumer-centric I
always like to reverse engineer I love
to use empathy I like to eliminate
friction I I sit backstage and I'm like
okay why why did somebody come today why
are they here what what can I provide
that makes this full-day investment
completely ROI positive like what is it
that people are looking for and and I
think a lot about macro and micro
inevitably given the course of my career
you know there may be somebody and a
large group of people that are looking
for me to give them a tactic you know
and I'm happy to do that
I can talk at nausea about my deep
belief that tik-tok is the first social
media platform in a very long time that
has the potential if the chips fall
properly to become the next Instagram
and being first is very valuable this is
always a game of being best but being
first is incredibly valuable and most
people are in no culture 90% of this
room if they're even aware of tik-tok
have started with no because they say
that's for 12 year old girls or for my
niece or my daughter my financial
service business my concrete pavement
business my peanut butter direct
consumer business that's not for tik-tok
and that has been the historical huge
mistake of businesses because facebook
was for
college kids and Instagram was for
taking photos and making it better and
on and on and on so I'm thrilled to come
here this evening and talk about the
tactics or the strategy at the most
narrow level of did they take the lights
off that sucks if you could put the
lights back on I would love that I'm
happy to talk about that I'm happy to
talk to you about the fact that LinkedIn
at this moment is acting the most
similar to anything that I've seen that
looks like Facebook looked in 2011 that
it is no longer just business content
that if you do makeup or if you want to
do you know Fitness content or wine
content that LinkedIn is now acting in a
way right the second in a way that will
reward you in your execution around
whatever you're talking about and that I
believe everybody in this conference
everybody should immediately like
tonight create their tick-tock and
LinkedIn accounts and spend 20 to 30
hours looking and consuming what content
works and immediately Wednesday start
producing three to four pieces of
content per platform I also am highly
aware that even though you came for me
your main questions are what's next
where's the opportunity I've now spent
the first four minutes giving it to you
I just gave it to you and 99 percent of
you will not do anything about it that
revelation over the last half decade for
me has led me to all the other places
thank you let's let be to every other
place I've gone like why are you so
insecure and concerned about judgment
that it stops you from making content is
your self-esteem so low that only
getting 5 likes on a tick-tock post is
so scary to you why why did that happen
how did that happen and so in my
incredible ambition from 2014 and 15 to
produce content that was deeply tactical
because I have no interest in being a
motivational speaker or anything that
looks like one
it led me to this place where I stand in
2019 trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
you're up to like why won't you take
this tactic that I'm giving you are you
so impatient that you're not willing to
spend a year of putting out content on
tick-tock and Linkedin to feel the
results do you believe that there's
something called passive income do you
think there's a hack is that what you're
about are you only interested in the
money to flex on Instagram to make other
people think you're winning like what
this has been the path that I've been
going through how how do I redefine
success that doesn't come in the form of
watches and private planes and stacks of
cash how do we recognize that the only
ambition of this collective room should
only be to be happy how how does that
happen how do I figure out how to do
that why are so few people using that as
their Northstar and that is what's led
me into the all the heavy [ __ ] all the
insecurities all the parenting all the
judgment all the happiness is silent as
[ __ ] on social and hate and anger is
loud as [ __ ] confusing people what's
actually happening in the world all
these dynamics the Anthropology behind
human behavior the fact that we're doing
all the same [ __ ] we've always done the
fact that social media has changed
nobody in this room it's just exposed
you and so I'm thrilled to give you the
[ __ ] keys I gave it to you in the
first 200 seconds of this talk I 420
thanks mom
it's really [ __ ] up it's really
fascinating my core skill has been to
understand where consumers spend their
time and attention and figure out what
pictures videos and room words to put in
those pipes I do it faster than most
which is why I've been able to be
successful I have a 20-year track record
from launching an e-commerce wine
business in 1996 to email marketing with
90 percent open rates to Google AdWords
for five cents a click to YouTube to
Twitter to Facebook to what I'm doing on
LinkedIn and tik-tok and text messaging
right this second I've given you
literally I've walked in here and in the
first three minutes giving you the
answer the answer to the biggest upside
for your business or ambition is to make
content as much of it as humanly
possible and make it where people
actually pay attention so they become
aware of what you want them to know it
always is better if you can find a room
that's less noisy and has less people
taking that attention right this second
right here in Melbourne at five [ __ ]
thirteen p.m. or whatever the [ __ ]
time it is the under priced platforms at
scale are tick tock and LinkedIn it
doesn't mean that Instagram and Twitter
and YouTube and a podcast and Facebook
aren't working they're actually working
remarkably well but there's a very big
difference they're mature enough now
that you actually have to be best not
first some of you are capable of being
best especially if you take a step back
and start deploying some self awareness
around what kind of communicator are you
are you good at video are you good at
written word are you good at audio this
is not about being like me they're you
know I can't write for [ __ ] it took me
years until I have enough scale to be
able to hire a writer that transcribes
my videos into written form for LinkedIn
or medium or things of that nature you
need to figure out how you communicate
but let me promise you this if you do
not produce written words pictures and
videos for this device you were
fundamentally irrelevant
you were declining in your business
opportunity on a second-by-second basis
whether that makes you sad whether that
makes you happy we are incredibly good
at demonizing technology we're really
good at it we're trying to limit our
kids screen time in a world where
they're gonna only live in a digital age
we judge people when they sit at dinner
and both have phones and we call that
sad without actually understanding those
two people actually don't like each
other and they're doing what they want
to be doing we demonize technology
technology unfortunately for us doesn't
care about our opinions it just does
technology doesn't give a [ __ ]
technology will keep advancing until
eventually the robots kill all of us but
for now there's plenty to do and for me
the real interesting thing and question
and debate and curiosity is why why does
this room continue to be able to consume
my content here the same thing over and
over over and over more content more
content more content and continue every
day to not what why what I need that
answer from the collective I got nothing
else I can give you 747 other clever
analogies and concepts this is the
easiest game of all time the reason you
know who Muhammad Ali is is not because
he was a great boxer it's because he
knew how to hack media Muhammad Ali's
great friendship with Howard Cosell
wasn't predicated on a great friendship
it was predicated on the fact that
Muhammad Ali was smartest [ __ ] and he
understood the television dictated
people's minds during that era and that
Howard Cosell was the most powerful
commentator in that genre he hacked
television that's why you all know who
he is yes he was great in the ring there
were other people that were great in the
ring
he's all-time legend because he hacked
the attention graft of society of that
time what's crazy was that television
print and radio had gatekeepers somebody
had a say you were good enough to be on
the show what's insane to me is that the
internet doesn't care who you are where
you came from what you look like it is
open for business and it's free I'm so
crippled by the opportunity in front of
everybody that it makes me laugh I'm
literally crippled by the fact that this
thing is free and we still find ways to
complain how many people here had a good
run on Facebook in 2011 12 13 just raise
your hands high I'm just curious
cuz it's not gonna be a lot I know that
so for the 80 people or so that just
raised their hands they knew that the
organic reach was crushing it and then
as the platform got bigger and ads
started to take over one more time raise
your hands high I'm sure every one of
you keep them up for a minute cuz I want
your neighbors to see this I'm sure
every one of you somewhere around 2015
16 started to get [ __ ] pissed right
saying shit's like sucks is [ __ ] me
my organic Reach is down the amount of
people that complain about Instagram not
getting as many likes today as they got
18 months ago because the algorithms
[ __ ] them makes me laugh
it's [ __ ] free how the [ __ ] is
something that's free [ __ ] you and so I
think about this [ __ ] every day
and I debate with myself what's the new
angle how do I get it done the biggest
reason I want to do Q&A is I want to go
more contextual not theory you can watch
me pontificate these thoughts on a daily
basis for free across all these
platforms I challenge you my friends
especially the ones that I know for a
long time or have seen it before whether
he or physically or spent the weekend
with me jamming I challenge you I
challenge you to execute you can't read
about doing push-ups you have to do them
I'm thrilled to keep giving you a high
with my content and make you feel like
you're doing something by consume
me but it's a false passing feeling
until you start making you are
irrelevant until you start making you
are irrelevant and you will regret every
person here which one more time I'm
positive it's not even a debate that 98%
of you will do nothing with the data I
give you today and the 98% in here in
three years who do nothing with the tick
tock and LinkedIn advice will regret it
because everybody will talk about how
good it was and how it's starting to
decline and how it's not as good as it
was in 2019 and 2020 everything is being
stripped away except for brand
everything is being stripped away the
internet kills everything in the middle
your location doesn't mean as much as it
used to because everybody gets [ __ ]
delivered all your advantages are being
commoditized by technology the only
thing that will be left is brand the
only way to build brand is to story tell
the weight a story tell in 2019 is not
like it was in 1974 it is not print ads
it is not ads in your b2b magazine it is
not television it is not radio it is not
billboards it is content on eleven to
twelve platforms that are consumed
through the mobile device and it will
change voice devices are getting close
next 5-10 years many of you will buy
[ __ ] through Alexa when Alexa dominates
the way we buy and you sell peanut
butter you're gonna really wish you
bought a brand because if I say in my
living room or in my bedroom or in my
kitchen hey Alexa send me peanut butter
Amazon is gonna pick what I'm getting if
I say Peter Pan peanut butter they're
gonna have to send that everybody here
needs to understand that they have to
build a brand that comes out of people's
mouths or they will over time continue
to lose massive more
get Cher you're mad at the websites that
are referral sites now that's child's
play to voice devices so this is the
world we live in it's very clear to me
what's happening
I'm desperate to figure out why people
are not creating content I've come to
learn that I've been blessed deeply with
incredible parents who gave me enough
self-esteem that it's very tough for me
to be in a place in my life right now
where I overthink posting something
because Johnnie pants 49 is gonna say
I'm a [ __ ] face and until I figure out
which I never will how to
disproportionately use the guilt and the
gratitude in my body for that framework
to over communicate to you of how to get
you to produce every single day without
worrying about ramifications of people's
judgement I will continue to come on
stage I will continue to produce content
I will continue to make it contextual to
the platform that I post on and I will
do that in perpetuity and so that is
what I come here to do I come here to
set a very simple framework content at
scale I believe that every person this
room should produce 100 pieces of
content for the internet every day yep
100 I know and there's people here to
post like four times a week a hundred a
day now how does that come that comes in
a form of 20 tweets that are just
written words your thoughts your
observations things you've seen things
you care about your opinions about your
business your industry your world four
five six posts on main Instagram
accounts everyone's so scared to post on
their Instagram account now because
everyone's using it like it's a [ __ ]
Museum everyone feels so much better in
stories cuz it goes away but the post
you put in your account has to be so
curated and looks such the part and it's
your own [ __ ] creative subjective
opinion if it looks good or not you give
no [ __ ] about the community it's just
about how many likes you get I was
looking at all the tweets and all the
posts
about this talk today you waiting for me
I looked at your social media accounts I
do it every speech the amount of people
here who desperately want to grow on
Instagram yet replied in nobody on their
last five posts when people actually
reply to the post there's a reason it's
called social media you post they say
[ __ ] you talk the audacity of how many
likes am I gonna get like the sheer non
interest in giving any [ __ ] about your
community and only worrying about what's
in it for you is the reason you're not
winning is the reason most people don't
win we are in a massively insecure and
selfish ecosystem and I'm trying to
break that and bring awareness to it and
create a framework of a conversation
that's what I'm up to
[Applause]
so in the spirit of that I think we
should go into QA and instead of me
talking let me do some listening and
some answering so the mics are back
there in the corners please line up
you're gonna have to line up sir let's
get into it alright mister you came with
a real [ __ ] outfit I carry money flee
AKA safely yep yeah
outfits for the kids at home understood
what's your take on early age for people
to get on to tick-tock and social media
I've got an eight-year-old who's heavily
addicted yep he's accounts currently
private yeah but he would post literally
40 videos a day it would be more if he
wanted to yep he's worked out the whole
how do I get so many likes because it's
a cumulative on tick-tock so he can see
that figure and he's figured out that if
he does 40 videos and 5 people like each
one he gets 200 likes a day so he's very
happy with learning math yeah he loves
math yeah it's great it's a so just
interested in your take on what my take
is I have a lot of passions about
parenting but I've zero interest in
telling any individual how to parent
their kids I think one of the wildest
thing to see is people give parenting
advice to other parents what I would say
is this evolution you and I are part of
a general
that saw videogames come in to culture
and every parent tried to limit kids on
video games and now and make them play
sports and now the biggest checks in the
world over the next decade are gonna be
for eSports stars not athletes of other
sports what I would say for every parent
is please play chess today is not the
world your eight-year-old is gonna live
in do you understand how different the
world is gonna look in 15 years 15 years
ago nothing we talked about existed not
the iPhone now Facebook not YouTube not
Twitter not in Simon Jesus in the last
15 years how many people here over the
age of 40 raise your hands
25 percent this room remembers the world
pre-internet itself I grew up the first
18 years of my life without the internet
like so what I would say to you is you
need you know your kid you need to
understand but there's a lot of good
happening on that screen time and the
question is what else would they be
doing watching TV playing video games
like you know this this fascination that
every kid is gonna be so healthy and eat
well and play outside all day and study
is [ __ ] ludicrous nobody [ __ ]
watches normal television do anything
like they all watch stuff when they want
have any complaints about when he can't
when he watches normal TV cuz it's fine
2019
not 1980 [ __ ] 9 yeah so my answer is
watch him and listen yeah but don't
demonize technology cuz every other
parent is yeah thank you thank you
hey bro hey brother
dude I was so excited to see you in
person don't tell everyone else here but
I actually left this event to stalk you
on Instagram try to find you but anyway
I was at the sports card store yeah I
was trying to [ __ ] us too late anyway no
no sir I literally had a thousand
business questions I could ask you but
the thing I'm focusing right now on is
learning and trying new things yes and
working on my mindset and so one of the
things you say is to get close to the
people you want to learn from yes and
sorry I want to ask a question not just
for myself but something the young
people will also get value from is I saw
an talk you did with your interns in
2018 but what you said was all of you
are here because you know some wizard
who knows me and it's close to me yes so
how would someone who doesn't know
someone like that get an internship at
Vayner find somebody that knows me it's
the truth it's it's it's human nature
right like you know we get 50 trillion
people that want to be interns at Vayner
and the reality is every every year
there are people who I've long
relationships with or dear friends and
family members who are calling in favors
and a nice percentage of our interns are
that but a nice percentage isn't however
you're thinking about the wrong way I
spent zero minutes except for that talk
with my interns this year see the way to
do it is to make map those hundred
people that you want to be with or like
and then be willing to eat [ __ ] I am and
I just moved to Melbourne this year and
seeing you thank you basically yeah I
think you asked questions to get the
coffee or you pay attention to what she
or he needs and offer to do it a level
of massive humility to just get as close
to P Diddy or Sara Blakely or whoever
you want to be like I think works and
like for example right now if you were
to ask me they answered me no because
I've got too much around me right now
but maybe in seven months it would be
yes it's being comfortable with getting
a ton of nose i watch people ask you
know they've heard this before
heard this from you before they asked
like two people and then they sent me an
email like you had bad advice I'm like
and I'm curious I'm like how many people
did you ask for I'm like how many times
once I'm like you're a [ __ ] loser
you want it so bad and you sent four
emails and you gave up you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] so that's what I think dude I'll
keep asking ya this video
d-roc how many times did you email me to
offer me to make a free video
d-roc emailed me five times before I
even replied and then when I said yes I
think it took a long time yeah I mean
it's just a [ __ ] everybody talks
about them wanting it's so bad and they
give up after like a [ __ ] effort if
you [ __ ] want it so bad it's about
it's the same thing with startups and
entrepreneurship everybody what guys do
you know how hard it is to be an
entrepreneur think about what you're
asking for you want to live your life on
your terms
the way we define entrepreneur right now
is real wealth you want to live a point
one percent life of course it should be
[ __ ] hard people are soft my man hi
my name is Sean from Melvin how's it
going really well
welcome to Melvin thank you my questions
about virtual reality and eSports okay
so I found you a week ago
thank you basically I think I'll never
have to come to another thing like this
because you've you've converted me
alright you've unlocked something I've
just started a podcast called virtually
pay up playable and it's to support the
developers out there who are creating
content for virtual reality so I'm
already putting into action what you've
recommended look my question is about
virtual reality as a platform and also
like eSports you've said that you're
interested in nostalgic brands like
Nintendo yes but my belief is that the
Nintendo of tomorrow is being born today
I believe that too and the boats and
they both coexist I believe to your
point that thirty five years from now
whatever we're doing that both fortnight
and Zelda can coexist you know yes
nostalgia is being born every day
but it also is not dying necessarily
right so there's a place for Pokemon and
Mickey Mouse today right so I believe
that I think the bigger and more
interesting question for me is how
patient are you we are a long way away
for virtual reality at scale at the
consumer level there's not a person in
this huge hall or this gorgeous city
that spends an hour a day in VR it's
just not there yet the technology is
moving very quickly and so it's just
like internet right Microsoft had
Microsoft comm in 1991 it really didn't
matter until 1999 so your biggest
thought to make what you're doing
practical is either a you get subsidized
by b2b because going to the footy
championship in September and a brand
having a VR thing they are that could
even happen
this September but normal humans us
playing VR games or doing anything VR is
super far away because we haven't even
started so that's that's what you have
to debate cuz timing matters sure right
like text messaging right now obsessed
I've been waiting for text messaging for
15 years I've been waiting to get into
your text and sell to you for my whole
life now is the time it's just starting
to happen right back to gaming ninja
just a couple hours ago announced his
cell number to get people into his so
it's just happening got it awesome
Cheers
hey how you going really well
this questions about the music industry
so I ran music studios I run a record
label managing artists we've just left
our ties with a major label because of
the way the their approach to releasing
content course what's your thoughts and
how much merit is in there is the
old-school way of what the labels do
cool second question then that basically
confirms what I was thinking
can I drop you an email introducing this
artist here I'm sorry my friend can I
drop you an email introducing an artist
to you I would love that
perfect could I send it to Gary at
vaynermedia and I'd also grab d-roc he's
running around he curates a lot of the
music we're using content done awesome
thank you good luck hey dude
Jordan Crawley here I've been watching
you since about 2015 and I guess this
could be the first episode of answer
Gary Vee cuz in answer to your question
I think the reason that I personally
didn't post and all of that I guess in
some respect I did give a [ __ ] about
what people thought of me you know like
you of course you kind of go along and
you think you know my beard can kind of
go [ __ ] amazing yeah but sometimes it
isn't it looks like [ __ ] right so so to
listen to what you say you know I think
it's finally really clicked for me this
year that um it's it's time to do a
podcast I've identified that I'm pretty
good on video I'm an actor on the side
as well but but I'm also in business and
I want to try and bring value as much as
I can
just like you recommend and then I'll
cut that down like I say yep
contextually market it real quick I'm
gonna just bring value for me podcast as
a Holy Grail cuz you get three things
you do the podcast you've got a podcast
you film it and now you have a ton of
content that you can use in all these
different platforms number three you
have a guest on and you can siphon her
his audience because their fan base is
gonna listen to the podcast so it's got
a triple threat to it I couldn't push
you more to start a podcast totally and
and and I guess it took a while to get
into my thick skull that that was the
to do it but you've been saying that for
years so I really appreciate that tip
that actually really does help man and
you're a [ __ ] smart dude bro your
execution is awesome your Hustle is
amazing and I love what your mind goes
to and I know how you interrupt quite a
lot of times but but you do it because
you know the value of what you're about
to say is going to bring it more to the
person than what they're about you know
it's funny it's not even that audacious
the reason I suck at interviewing people
and everybody wants to punch me in the
mouth when I have guests on is actually
twofold one I'm so hard scheduled that I
have to get it done in a certain period
of time and we don't post produce we
don't clean up anything yeah yeah and I
have a disease which is my gift which is
I know what the [ __ ] people gonna say
before they're done with the sentence
yeah and so I'm thinking that I want to
get as much out of this person for the
audience and so I'm willing to take the
heat that I'm a jerk to get more value
out of the person not from what I'm
going to say and so that's kind of how I
think about it yeah so my question is
you're big on contextualizing or canned
context and and when you're looking at
musically or what's it called now tock
tick tock sorry okay and and Linkedin
what do you think about the psychology
in regards to your marketing to the
market and and and how should you behave
as you know Instagram and Facebook so
tick tock I think about it being a young
community right it's young and so I'm
thinking about that or it's the parents
of young because they're watching that
so I'm thinking about what they're doing
in there it's entertainment oriented
it's music oriented so those are the
things I'm thinking about and then I'm
looking for memes right one of the
things that's exploding on tick-tock
right now is filming your phone with
content of you on a different platform
and you doing something with that so I
started filming my keynotes and talking
to the tic-tock community over it so I'm
looking for nuances and psychology
LinkedIn is a business crowd so all of a
sudden if I'm selling makeup I'm
thinking five tips of how to get your
makeup ready in three you know in three
minutes or while you're at the airport
or so I'm always reverse engineering the
thought process of them in their feed
because you and I are different when
we're
have twitter then when we're looking at
Instagram then we're looking at YouTube
the psychology is different obviously
you've picked up on that so that's all
I'm doing
and I'm testing and learning and I don't
think I have to be right I'm just
putting out so much content that the
quantity is helping me to get to higher
quality most people think you're giving
up quality when you do quantity it's
only because they're stuck in a
philosophical debate I'm [ __ ]
actually out here making would it be
fair to say that tic TOCs like the
McDonald's approach where you get the
happy meal in the playground and you
have customers for life and then the the
the LinkedIn approach is a bit more
professional and where we're getting
caught up as we're trying to be too
professional probably I think both those
analogies work other than by the time
those tick tock kibbutz grow up you
might not be selling them at a
McDonald's you might have grown up and
opened the three-star restaurant yeah
because they may not be there anymore
yeah right myspace is not here anymore
yeah can I get a photo dude sure thank
you
Thanks all right hi gary was up all good
so design to you actually said teach me
about life so you keeping it simple over
the mic I can hear you alright so my
goal my goal in life is to own it all
just like what I have in this cab so I'm
a 22 year old kid okay I'm still in
medical school right now okay
it was yeah it was kind of hard because
I don't actually want to be in medical
school
so don't yeah but I couldn't quit
I'm worried in my third year I got I
know huh well if I quit now I won't get
any degree and are you gonna be a doctor
huh are you gonna be a doctor
well actually my I don't want to be a
doctor I want to be a hospital owner for
me being a doctor is like being a
employee okay and for me being an
employee is not something in my blood so
I can't be - so why are you finishing
Medical School
it's because I was at that time I was
good at biology and that's a [ __ ] no I
mean when I was in high school I was
pretty good at but I'm not talking about
last year no no I'm talking about why
are you gonna spend the next two and a
half years of your life doing something
that you fully believe has nothing to do
with what you want to do with your life
other than appeasing your parents it
makes no sense
yeah I know but like I already talked to
my parents let me promise you the
easiest way to not have it all is to not
understand why you do [ __ ] okay yeah
right well if you ask me why I do it
right now I just want to I just think
that it could be a good kind of like
springboard for me in the future as a if
I get the name of a doctor all right
okay so in my opinion okay
sorry if I make you confused but no I'm
not confused I think you're confused
yeah that's why I asked you to question
well that's why I'm here I'm [ __ ]
listening yeah here I'm trying to help
sorry for being nice no no you're being
you're being awesome
what I'm doing is desperately trying to
help you have a conversation with
yourself because you're pulling from
you're half pregnant right you know I'm
worried about somebody who's
pontificating with a hat of saying I
wanted all yeah cuz you're talking real
macro and grey yeah but you're going so
Micro and black and white yeah which is
okay I want you to just be self-aware
about that because there's so many
people like you that are actually going
quite conservative and playing defense
but talking about offense and I think
that creates a very tough struggle
within somebody yeah actually that's
true I mean oh [ __ ] yeah I mean I want
to play the offense but you're playing
defense yeah I could
I want to play the offense but my like I
don't know my mentality said look if you
play the offense and then when you do it
when you did it like you're gonna get
interventions every single time like for
example I did I decide on myself that I
want to do a martial art class okay
because it's I believe from that it's
good for my body okay for strength and
also like to focus okay and then when I
did it
my parents sparring class which is we're
just normal like in martial art does
yeah I got hurt and when I go home my
parents told me what do what do you get
hurt I was like well I'm not good enough
so stopped going to the martial art
class and I was like telling my parents
don't do that well I'll just think
either your your bank account and you
know you can't do your martial right
guys anymore yes so look what do you
think should I do
I think you should stop relying on your
parents all right parents who pay for
things have control parents who don't
pay for things have no control you're
living within the framework of your
parents there's nothing wrong with that
it just ends up bad quite often yeah
that's what like I'm trying to get away
from them stop taking their money yeah
in a way no no I'm gonna make it very
simple for you yeah don't take their
money ever again okay like I want to I
want to start to do that and when I tell
you that if you never take their money
again that you will have obnoxious level
of happiness and freedom it would break
your [ __ ] face if you knew how much
get off the payroll
yeah thank you bro you're welcome
hey Gary yo that's a bit loud so my name
is Zack and I'm just gonna start and say
I'm slightly nervous and I need a pee
but first and foremost consuming your
content really changed my perspective on
life
I think and I've finally figured out how
to be happy and at peace regardless of
where I'm at life so thank you for that
now getting on to my question so from
consuming your content it inspired me to
start my own podcast called running from
comfort and I've had guests on and I
won't lie it kind of [ __ ] sucks at
the moment but I'm dealing with the fact
that it sucks cuz it will get better of
course it will we suck at everything you
know bad we were driving the first year
like bad oh my dad used to like
literally skits out bad mojo so of
course that's gonna be bad at first
anyways few of the people I've
interviewed on there they're
entrepreneurs and the whole business is
based on social media okay I asked them
the question how is social media
affected like your life in terms of like
your personal relationships and
potentially your mental health and I've
had two people say that it's actually
negatively affected their mental health
they've had to find ways to manage that
so I want to ask you because you are the
king of content you spend a lot of time
on social media you're posting all the
time is there any way that you sort of
disconnect from a social media world for
your mental health or do you find it
doesn't affect you negatively um it
doesn't affect me negatively
I don't disconnect from it on purpose in
any shape or form because what I
completely believe and understand to be
true is that social media exposes us it
doesn't change us the two people that
told you it's been a negative don't
realize that they were in a negative
place prior to it and if it was never
invented they were insecure and broken
before it and one more just quickly real
quick on this everybody who's blaming
social for FOMO we see him
everybody was blaming social media for
making us bad
Facebook didn't make you write a thing
single thing you wrote it this is
exposing us so if you're the kind of
person that lays in bed on a Friday
night at 9:30 goes through a feed and
sees your best friends at a party and
that [ __ ] with you you were insecure
that Instagram didn't make you insecure
your DNA parenting and environment made
you insecure this is speeding up the
process of exposing us which will lead
to much better conversations social
media is being demonized because we hate
to be held accountable
sure now quickly about a year ago I
wrote you down as my dream guest my
podcast so will you come on and how do i
hook that up nope however however if you
email me a year from today and in the
title put I was the guy who asked the
unsecure question of two people I asked
you to be on the podcast you said nope
you told me the email in a year if you
email me a year from today with all that
information then the answer is yes I'm
holding you to that
I will deliver big hey Gary sorry but
notice first of all thank you so much
for replying to my DMS just before happy
to do it
and I ask you what the very first person
asks you if there is any internship
opportunities no but I've got the answer
no just a quick one so I just started
working in marketing automation okay in
b2b oh come on Carol okay so I just want
to get your thoughts on where you think
it's going and how I can how can I do it
better well I think automation and
technology is amazing but I think it
gets you to a place where humans still
need to be involved I think people often
think about AI or ml or things of that
nature and think it eliminates humans
and I think what it does is it
eliminates things that humans are
wasting their time on and so I think you
could do it better by understanding the
mix of humans and
nology awesome yep that's it thank you
welcome how are you Gary SuperDuper um
right
I run multiple social media accounts
okay do you think that a lot of people
benefit from rapid testing different
products across them to find their
nation I think at some level yeah I love
speed yeah and if you have a bunch of
different accounts and you're trying to
sell chocolate or t-shirts or you know
racing gear you know I don't think
there's anything wrong you know what you
need to be careful of is that the
audience starts to check out cuz you're
spamming them too much yeah so you have
to find the right cadence of rapid
learning to not lose organic reach out
of lack of trust from the content you
put out but for the most part I like the
thesis yeah and how would you diversify
your audience to different platforms by
changing the content you know and I'm
gonna use this moment you know so many
muscled dudes and bikini girls say the
same thing to me which is like hey like
I really want to talk about vegan
lifestyle but every time I do I get no
likes and every time I put out a bikini
shot I get a billion likes and I'm like
but you want to talk about vegan
lifestyle they're like yeah I'm like so
put out vegan lifestyle for a year and
eventually you'll get more likes people
are so caught up by the Machine that
they care more about likes than their
own happiness that's true that's my
answer to you I appreciate it thank you
hey Gary hey going okay
my name's Sahni and I just want to take
a moment to thank you for your content
also it helps people that who aren't
interested in business and
entrepreneurship as well I've had a
plane I have friends with mental health
issues and I've said to them look I know
you can't get out of bed today just
watch a couple of videos and it's
actually helped them so so much so thank
you thank you my question is about the
relationship between the entrepreneur
and the creative okay what should a
natural-born creative look for in an
entrepreneurial partner and what do you
know
humility humility and the other half of
that question is what do you look for in
a creative humility same-same because it
takes humility to feed creativity if I
as an owner think my opinion of the
picture video you made is right and need
to give you so much feedback before it
goes out that's my own ego and
insecurity slowing down the process we
need to find right not be right and
that's based on humility okay thank you
welcome get it Gary how you doing Mike
doing well how are you very good thank
you
now first of all I'm starting a startup
behind us on a play this is a vegan
meals business my question to you is
that as a business owner or starting up
a business
I want to make decisions which I am
because I know there is no other way to
start a business yes the question is
that how do you make level-headed
decisions all the time and if you do
first of all and if you´d I do how do
you
I feel historically I've been really
good at it because I'm completely
unemotional mm-hmm it's business okay
well then probably the answers the next
part of my question that if the decision
you make doesn't turn out to be the
right decision I move on how do you move
on like how you not by not over judging
myself okay all right well that's good
thank you
I mean and let's play it out like what
are you gonna beat up yourself the rest
of the year like to me life is about
alternatives I make decisions superfast
I make decisions because the speed and
that the decision is more valuable than
the debate because if I'm right I'm
right and if I'm wrong who gives a [ __ ]
I'm not sitting I'm sitting up here as a
byproduct of getting facebook twitter
youtube instagram snapchat linkedin
right I spent a lot of time on peach on
social cam on vero on viddler those
didn't work out when you make this
Asians and you don't dwell the net out
pieces everybody here is trying to in
the world what you're asking is you're
trying to be three four three right you
want to be three and out three right
decisions no wrong decisions I'm trying
to be 118 292 got it no let me explain
everybody's looking for perfection cuz
perfection is our the skies of
insecurity I'm just doing because I'm
not worried about the ramifications as
long as you're not dead or out of
business no mistake is a big deal where
this goes is people being worried about
judgment see I like it best when things
look bad I'm a wartime general in a
world of peacetime generals that's an
entrepreneur that's why I'm scared
people are getting into this when
they're not you starting a business with
that being a top concern is a humongous
vulnerability doesn't mean you can't get
over it I'm just trying to make sure
during this era of everybody being a
[ __ ] entrepreneur that entrepreneurs
need to really communicate what it's
about so that other people don't just go
into it cuz it looks good because it's
really hard to be a zebra when you're a
[ __ ] penguin cool thank you and two
more questions one I'm pretty sure
you'll say yes to can I have a picture
okay thank you and secondly my business
model is because the lifestyle vegan
lifestyle you talked about earlier I'm
trying to change perceptions of the
world about what vegan food is about you
don't have to do that by building a
business that sells vegan no but the
thing is what I'm trying to create
flavors and the taste which you are used
to as a meat-eater but in a different
way so cool how can I send you that meal
so that you can taste it you can send me
the picture of you and me right now to
Gary at vaynermedia and we'll give you
the address then I'll taste it thank you
you're welcome
gonna take a picture you can
hi I'm Rebecca
I work in people in culture and my
question is so I'm really passionate
about empowering people to envision
what's possible and help ignite their
spark okay so my question to you is what
would you say to anyone who feels like
they don't know what they are I'm who
they are and is struggling to find what
they're passionate about usually I would
tell them that their insecurities or
their you know lack of being able to
find it is predicated on fear which was
instill to them by somebody else and
that they need to reconcile that before
they can start looking forward most
people like this is one big thing like
this is I'm given the same answer over
and over this is completely predicated
on fear and being worried that you're
judged 99% of this Hall is still in
[ __ ] high school the reason most
people don't know who they are is they
haven't tried the reason they haven't
tried is they're worried what people
gonna say I would tell them to tell
their mother to go [ __ ] themselves or
their father or their sister or their
spouse or their [ __ ] miserable best
friend that they need to start cutting
out some of the time they spend with
them cut out negativity that's what I
would tell them sure Gary [ __ ]
Vee what up baby all right you said how
hip-hop rules the world I believe it now
I've seen in many people in the music
industry have seen rap rap game change
in australia/new there's a new market
for for people coming up and pretty much
my question was with the middleman being
cut out with the internet exposing
everyone is there a specific truth to
focus on when podcasting producing
content etc yes the truth it's
interesting the way you ask the question
if you used a different word you happen
to use truth but no matter what you
would have passed the answer is going to
be the truth when you story tell which
is what musics about it's unbelievably
obvious there's a reason most artists
first album always over-index
it's their life
truth if they right got it yeah they
come up and they're come up and as you
know the reason the second album is a
struggle is now they've made it and the
only thing in that two years they can
write about is now the floss of it what
a lot of them don't want to do that and
so they start stretching the truth
guessing the truth is your answer in
addition to that what would you provide
any advice for any artists managers out
there to force their artists to put out
content you know where I sit on this 365
days a year on soundcloud and Spotify
365 if you're capable it sucks that
Prince died and there was a shitload of
music in that vault you know like I wish
that music made it out we live in the
internet now put out the [ __ ] music
how's it going really well let's get
closer my name is Rhys so I'm a
videographer and photographer and from a
brand perspective what do you look for
outside of humility in a content creator
so if you are looking to outsource more
I don't make that call usually because I
don't really overthink it you know I
don't really know how to look for
somebody that's great at finding angles
or knows how you know it's not my skill
set so what I look for is tenacity and
and just serendipity but that might be a
much better question to dirac of what he
looks for like for me I think creative
is subjective and so I'm not really
looking for much to be honest I really
am NOT yeah cool and with that then from
looking at other brands what would you
give his advice to other brands in terms
of getting a creative most other people
I think have an opinion that they enjoy
having the power of that subjective call
so I for brands I would tell them to
deploy far more humility and let
audience have an impact not their
ownselves for creators I would say look
for people that like what you do and
just ask a hundred people and take the
two that like you you know it's
completely subjective like I don't know
like the shirt you're wearing right now
you clearly thought that was a good idea
I also think it's a good idea I think
you look good but the dude sitting right
in front of you he might think it's a
shitty [ __ ] shirt you know what I
mean we need to have a much bigger
debate around subjectivity and the sheer
audacity and politics and insecurities
people use to judge creative yeah okay
Cheers
I made well thank you
straightforward question I think there
is a lot of opportunity in this economy
and also a lot of distractions yes as a
professional with a limited time trying
to figure out where they want to start
in business how do you think I can best
focus on how I'm gonna make that
decision and also where I should start
in the way of social media I think you
need to think about the thing that you
like the most sure it really this is
people understand unless you really love
what you do somebody else is gonna love
it more and outwork you yeah you know
what I mean
like and by the way it didn't seem like
it made sense seven years ago to start a
podcast around Pokemon but if you stayed
consistent loved it and inevitably if
you were good at it it's probably if the
number one Pokemon podcast right now
could probably make $500,000 a year in
advertising it didn't seem right what
you might like the most is buying bottle
caps at flea markets it doesn't seem
obvious but I really believe that that's
where the Internet's going the long tail
of niche interests at enough scale that
brands want to tap into that and so I
think the the hobbies and interests of
many in this room is actually there
unlock right you know I really
leave that it's a passion period
commitment period nari pre Simmons needs
to be set correct that Gary because
mainly like then results because here's
why it gets into a far more interesting
debate you ended up selling ties instead
of starting a footy podcast the tie
company allowed you to make two hundred
thirteen thousand a year when all the
profits are done the footy company let
you make 113 some may say it was the tie
business I say it's the footy business
because you're dramatically happier at
113 and the only thing to do different
was not buy dumb [ __ ] that has to be the
conversation and it is not the
conversation now you understand how are
you about yourself very well um my
question is like everyone in this room I
love to grind and I love to work hard
okay how do you know when you're going
in the right direction or the wrong
doesn't you just sure don't how did you
know when you would I didn't you just
did it I just knew I liked it and you
love free dudes loves what I did right
you know again cuz I always reference
her when I'm here
Barbara long gay who's sitting in row 2
who I love very much when I bought
hundreds of cases of Spring Mountain
1995 read from Barbara long gay in New
Jersey in 1997 I didn't know if that was
right or wrong but what I knew now many
years later is trying to sell something
nobody else could sell and the
creativity it took me to move those
hundreds of cases taught me something
that I later used I don't know what to
say
that's a real life story we both know it
you know what I mean I didn't know you
know when I launched winelibrary.com and
Barbara will tell you that most of the
industry thought it was stupid and that
I should have opened the second store
cuz that's what you did you opened a
second store not a dot-com there was no
internet when I did email I should have
been doing a cattle
when I did Wine Library TV everybody
thought it was stupid or self-serving I
never know people are not patient do you
understand that's why I push it so hard
yeah how the what do you think I'm a
[ __ ] genie from the future I don't
know if it's gonna work people are
scared to lose three or four years of
their life people over especially kids
piss me off they over value their time
that Gary I don't waste time like your
time's not worth dick [ __ ] it's like
free work people like [ __ ] you Gary I'm
not doing free work I'm like cool get
somebody to pay for it oh you couldn't
now what oh you didn't think that maybe
doing free work would give an example to
somebody else that then will pay you you
[ __ ] audacious lazy [ __ ] you like
that one in the back right right how the
[ __ ] people complaining about doing
free work when nobody's [ __ ] paying
them what the [ __ ]
I gave a shitload of free speeches not
anymore
I know time's up but I'm gonna try to
get a couple more how are you I'm good
it means I bow down to you I think I
started following you since 2015 and I
uh got obsessed with two words
self-awareness and emotional
intelligence yes and it was like my
dream to become an entrepreneur but
after getting obsessed with two words
and then I started working on myself and
then I have realized that how weak I am
to start this journey good and since
four years I'm just working on it I'm
still I I know that what my strengths
and weaknesses are so and a few months
ago even I heard one of your speech that
you were saying that you want to teach
American people about to s sacrifice and
saving yes and then I started thinking
like okay I hope my spiritual guru as
well but you are my entrepreneur grew as
well as the spiritual guru because I
have started my spiritual journey with
you as well without using a spiritual
world you are spreading spirituality
that's what I have realized because
whenever you speak you speak about
humanity every everybody so my question
is so my question is what's the main
role of spirituality in business and as
well as as a business personality or any
business organization how we can
contribute in the society business as a
tool so I think it's a tremendous
observation I think from my standpoint
you know it's funny you brought it up
it's about self-awareness right I think
that I don't think that people
understand how being selfless is such an
advantage in business yeah you know I
don't know what to say that's the answer
like you know if you think about
spirituality and I'm not educated enough
in it which is why I don't speak to it
but it's in me which is why it is
obvious it's gonna be based on good [ __ ]
yeah like like to me it's like doing the
right thing I think businesses have an
incredible opportunity to do the right
thing it's it's how I see it I believe
that I'm on a mission to show the world
that you can be a killer who also
happens to be a sweetheart
you know and so I think that's the role
especially as governments continue to go
in a direction of nationalism and
insular vulnerabilities it's an
opportunity for global businesses to
make a bigger positive impact and I
think we will reward those businesses
over the next century so that's the
future we can see that I'd like it to be
true and I don't know but I know that if
I execute at least I can create an
example yeah thanks you good how are you
super I want to give you a little bit of
context before I ask you the question
you got it so I work two part-time jobs
okay as well as working freelance okay
Donna okay also selling be it all online
selling what be it oil online beard oil
oil you understand there was a dude with
a huge [ __ ] paper I have a chat to be
back later or you know there's a lot of
bearded dudes here I know but I'm lucky
enough to love what I do you're liking
it
I love what I do I'm a designer I work
in marketing so I love it okay what I I
know the con I know that part of what I
have to do is a lot of content okay
what I struggle is is with knowing what
to actually do just do something so
here's where people get caught I don't
know either but every day you make five
pieces of content you're gonna get a lot
of nose okay and over time you're gonna
find some yeses so you test and try go
figure
thanks man you get it yeah like there's
no right answer you know it might be you
just talking it might be a video of
somebody applying the beard oil it might
be you interviewing on skype the person
that produces the beard oil it might be
the story of how you got the beard oil
it might be a pictures of dudes with
huge red beards like I don't [ __ ]
know I just know that you need to do all
of them and find the answer what about
mimosa graphic designer so what about as
a
ghazan and their creative what kind of
content would you produce as a graphic
designer and creative I would [ __ ]
make pictures of people putting beard
oil on their [ __ ] beards or I would
make up a funny mythical tale of if you
put this beard oil on your beard you get
to hook up with the prettiest girl in
the world or save your mom from a
burning building or you would [ __ ]
[ __ ] be creative right can I take your
photo with you but you can't yeah can I
get one more in alright last one
hey Gary how are you first of all I
wanted to say a [ __ ] love you man
pretty much you got me into actualize in
my [ __ ] I was in my bedroom always on my
bed just dreaming away about business
idea here and there and nothing [ __ ]
happened and then I started moving built
a team got a couple programmers with me
from University are studying in the
Masters level and we're getting [ __ ]
done we're moving I just want to know
how do I find the balance between going
too hard and going too soft
cuz I've always had this problem with I
burn myself out cuz I go way too hard
for too long is it possible that you
were aiming for money no okay [ __ ] about
money that's coming later I'm 18 years
old I got time so why would you burn out
cuz I just go so hot I don't sleep
[ __ ] sweet stupid hot I'll give you a
really good let me let me use this
opportunity I sleep six seven or eight
hours a night everyone's like you only
sleep what three hours I'm like no
[ __ ] sleeps important so sleep
seven or eight hours don't get caught up
in the [ __ ] that sleep isn't like
that sleeps for losers or not
entrepreneurs like sleep [ __ ] no what
are you burned-out dick you got a sleep
yeah and one more thing right if I can
in the next five to ten years build this
business up to five million dollars plus
would you give me the opportunity to
pitch you an investment
sure and can I take a photo with you yes
I can't read what that says I don't know
what crew is you mean like do an event
ok email me
sure sneak it in real fast Gary Gary um
my partner Brian cut down what talks
about getting your partner on board if
she's not on the same page it's not
gonna happen right okay
I want my partner's safe I want her to
come join my business kangaroo hopping
tours we do sightseeing and winery tours
what is your feedback or advice on
getting somebody who saved comment join
me for the unknown journey to listen to
them right I mean there's so much
audacity and entrepreneurs to force
their mates their partners their spouses
on their journey yeah you've got to ask
them what they want okay okay I asked
that yeah yeah she says to not do that
no really yeah so this is real [ __ ]
right now it's why I let you ask the
question because relationship stuffs
super fascinating to me yeah first
entrepreneurs need to have a
conversation with their partner about
what do they want yeah usually or often
you can start negotiating given takes
sometimes you can't you have two very
different people then you have to have
that real conversation okay you know
because some entrepreneurs would die if
they can't do what they do